I'm feeling pretty good I'm really
nervous I went to sleep last night a
little unsure and then I woke up this
morning and went right now I keep going
back and forth between good idea bad
idea good idea that idea how great I
feel like I'm gonna throw up the pain
doesn't super intimidating at this point
the less I think about it I think the
happier I'll be
I'm getting an anchor on my wrist my
tattoo is in memory of my cat Maisie
Santa my girlfriend she's like yeah do
that one so my idea for a tattoo is a
smiley face on my butt let's do this
thing
all right so we're thinking like Xiaomi
like one of your french girls their
massage that comes with this as well
okay oh mama that sounds no fun at all
that's very of you guys really oh my god
that's really not anywhere nearly as
painful as I thought it would be I hate
getting my teeth clean way more than I
hate this I got this this is so it is
weird like as I'm doing this like
realizing like this is forever
what are you done that's it oh my god
you did it you deal you dealt with me I
did it I hated all them
haha the face on my bed I like can't
believe this just I can't believe it's
real we did it this is what I think
cocaine honestly it feels like I just
got off a roller coaster I thought it
was gonna hurt a lot more it feels like
getting stung by little babies these
dudes who complain about how much it
hurts have you never watched their
eyebrows before if you're thinking about
getting a tattoo and pain is your
biggest fear like do not worry at all
maybe worry about the mistake that will
haunt you for the rest of your life like
a smiley face on your butt but don't
worry about the pain like that's totally
not a problem
I'm now thinking about this video living
on YouTube in like the hundreds of
thousands of people we're going to see
my but which in a way is more permanent
than the tattoos will ever be